you lived in New York City most of your
career when I work to see one star not
live in New York City that I mean you
the New York City was a big part of your
life Trump in New York City all those
years both of you famous people did you
know Trump before he got into politics
that you met him not really I we would
be in the same room every once in a
while because it'd be being invited the
same things and I you know I'd see him
and I would I wouldn't like look cross
room or like gee that seems like he
seems like a good people you know he
seems like he seems like someone I
really want to get to that and so no I
didn't I had one this wasn't even in
exchange I remember the height at the
height of The Sopranos it was they had a
screening at the beginning of a season
the right to first episodes at Radio
City Music Hall and they invited a lot
of people and show business and and
other noted people and if there's 5,000
seats in Radio City he was sitting right
in front of me and my wife was so for
some reason before the lights went out I
just I just had an impulse and I just
said as loudly as I could and there's
5,000 people in this theater I I said
that is the worst comb-over I've ever
seen
[Applause]
he live where Oh show that face to that
camera right there okay I'll say that is
the worst comb-over I have ever seen
[Applause]
we're gonna go back to three uh-huh so
he sees that it's me it's like he's
going it's not worth it I'm not that's
it's my and I have not seen him I may
have not been I've not spoken to him
since I've been president I I assume
that I will yeah you'll probably run
into him at the eggroll the Easter Egg
Roll
I thought they have at the White House
I'm Jewish well done yeah isn't he gonna
throw a seder I think he did and he
didn't come yeah yeah I think I'm not
sure I want to make sure we have our
facts straight before we go on the air
with anything like that okay well you'll
cut that and cut it out yeah no he
didn't go to the same
you